[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait comme une éclipse une nuit plein
d'étoiles sur le port de
Tunisie
au café des délices
[Musique]
souvenirs se voilent ça fasse et le tram
et la blancheur des voiles des femmes
tenant un fils
[Musique]
dans ses mains au café des délices
attention
[Musique]
le baiser qui fait mal à Port elle canta
oui
[Musique]
les noyaux d'abricot pour toi c'était
des billes
et soirée de fête qu'on faisait dans nos
têtes au plage de ma mère attention tout
le monde
[Musique]
y aller
frappez mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ce qu'est qui s'éloigne vers un monde
nouveau
une vie qui s'arrête pour un jour qui
commence c'est peut-être une chance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu l'oublieras pas y aller
c'est parfums d'autrefois il est liée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est incroyable
merci ma chérie franchement j'adore
j'adore j'adore